[Music]
so far we've discussed the meaning
applications and the formulation of
linear programming problems we will now
discuss how a linear programming problem
is solved before we begin can you tell
me what an optimal solution is the
maximum or the minimum value of an
objective function for the given problem
is the optimal solution but the question
is how do we solve a linear programming
problem well there are different ways to
solve these problems the problems having
two variables can be solved graphically
like in this example there were only two
decision variables x and y while in this
example we had three decision variables
and hence we can't solve it graphically
in such cases the problems are solved
using the simplex method for now we will
be discussing the problems based on the
graphical solutions to solve a linear
inequality with two variables on a graph
we will use a coordinate plane we know
that there are four quadrants in a
coordinate plane as the decision
variables in a linear programming
problem should satisfy the non
negativity constraint the values of x
and y should not be less than zero it
means they will lie in the first
quadrant only therefore to solve these
problems on a graph we need to use only
this quadrant for better understanding
let's solve this linear programming
problem graphically in this problem we
need to find the maximum profit which is
denoted by the objective function Z is
equal to 50 X plus 18 y so let us find
the values of x and y which satisfy this
linear inequalities as the solution
needs to be found using a graph let's
represent these inequalities on a
coordinate plane how do we graph
inequalities we will first write the
corresponding equations for these
inequalities
can you write them here that's right
these are the corresponding equations
next we need to graph the lines of these
equations and we can do that by finding
the coordinates of x and y intercepts
let me help you with the x and
y-intercepts of the first equation for
the x intercept we substitute y equal to
0 we get the value of x as 50 so the
coordinates of the x intercept are 50
comma 0 and to find the coordinates of
the y intercept we substitute X as 0
that gives us the value of y as 100 the
coordinates of the y intercept are 0
comma 100 similarly we get the X and the
y intercepts of the second equation with
these points let's draw the two lines
representing these two equations on a
graph let's mark the four points first
with this the first line can be drawn
like this it represents the equation 2x
plus y is equal to 100 likewise let's
draw the second line representing this
equation give it a try
here's the line representing the
equation X plus y is equal to 80 so how
will this graphical presentation help us
find the optimal solution we will first
mark the feasible region of this graph
do you know what a feasible region is
it's the common region determined by all
constraints of a linear programming
problem each point of a feasible region
satisfies the linear inequalities of the
problem so let's mark the feasible
region for this problem if we consider
only these two linear constraints all
the points of this quadrant will satisfy
the given inequalities and hence this
entire quadrant can be the feasible
region however if we consider these two
constraints as well the feasible region
will get restricted to the region or a B
and C as you can see the two lines
intersect at point
20 comma 60 the region within these four
corner points is the feasible region of
this problem as each and every point of
this region will satisfy the linear
constraints of the problem for instance
let's take the point 30 comma 40 if we
substitute these values for x and y
respectively in the linear inequality X
plus y is less than equal to 80 we will
see that the point satisfies the linear
inequality in this way every point
within and on the boundary of the
feasible region can be the feasible
solution for the given problem it meets
the points on and within the region
satisfy the linear constraints then how
will we find the optimal solution since
there are many possible solutions for
this problem we will use the corner
point method to find the maximum profit
now what's a corner point method in this
method the solution of a linear
programming problem lies on the corner
point of a feasible region the
coordinates of the corner points are
substituted for the values of x and y in
the objective function in this example
points o a B and C are the corner points
of the feasible region we will evaluate
the objective function by substituting
these points as values of x and y one by
one first let's find the value of Z at
point O the coordinates of point O are 0
comma 0 50 times 0 plus 18 times 0 gives
us 0 likewise can you fill in these
values of Z for the sigmoid we get the
value of Z as 1440 2084 the third and
2500 for the fourth point so we have all
the four values of Z at the corner
points of the feasible region since our
objective is to maximize Z the optimal
solution lies at Point C 50 comma 0
because the value of Z is maximum at
Point C
this is how we solve a linear
programming problem graphically let me
ask your question here is the feasible
region of this problem bounded or is it
unbounded to answer this question we
first need to discuss the meaning of the
terms bounded region and unbounded
region and why did we choose only the
corner points and how did we find the
feasible region we will continue the
discussion in our next lesson
[Music]